easily the most quoted number people
give you and they're publicizing
information about their credit cards is
the APR and I think you might guess or
you might already know that it stands
for annual percentage rate annual
percentage rate percentage rate and what
I want to do in this video is to
understand a little bit more detail on
what they actually mean by the annual
percentage rate and do a little bit math
to get the real or the mathematically or
the effective annual percentage rate so
I was actually just browsing the web and
I saw some credit card that had an
annual percentage rate of they say it's
a twenty two point nine percent annual
percentage rate but then right next to
it they say that we have zero point zero
six two seven four percent daily daily
periodic rate periodic rate which to me
this right here this piece right here
tells me that they compound the interest
on your credit card balance on a daily
basis and this is the amount that they
compound so where do they get these
numbers from well if you just take point
zero six if you just point take point O
six two seven four and multiply by 365
days in a year you should get this
twenty two point nine and let's see if
we get that and of course this is
percentage so this is a percentage here
and this is a percent here let me get
out my trusty calculator and see if that
is what they get so if I take if I take
point O six two seven four and remember
this is a percent but I'll just ignore
the percent sign so so as a decimal I
would actually add two more zeros here
but 0.06 two seven four times 365 is
equal to right on the right on the money
twenty two point nine percent would say
hey Sal what's wrong with that that's
you know they're charging me 0.06 two
seven four percent per day they're going
to do that for 365 days a year
so that gives me twenty two nine point
twenty two point nine percent and my
reply to you is that they're compounding
on a daily basis they're compounding
this number on a daily basis
so if you were to give them $100 and if
you didn't have to pay some type of a
minimum balance and you just let that
$100 ride for a year you wouldn't just
go them one hundred twenty two point
nine dollars they're compounding this
much every day so if I were to write
this as a decimal so let me just write
that as a decimal so point zero point
zero six two seven four percent if I as
a decimal this is the same thing as zero
point zero zero oh six two seven four
these are the same thing right one
percent is 0.01 so 0.06 percent is point
zero zero zero six as a decimal now this
is how much they're charging every day
and if you watch the compounding
interest video you know that if you if
you wanted to figure out how much you
how much total interest you would be
paying over total year you would take
this number add it to one add it to one
so we have one point this thing over
here point zero zero zero six two seven
four and instead of so instead of just
taking this and multiplying it by 365
you take this number and you take it to
the 360 fifth to the 360 fifth power you
multiply it by itself 365 times that's
because if I have one dollar in my
balance on day two I'm going to have to
pay this much times one dollar 1.000 six
two seven four times a dollar on day two
I'm gonna have to pay this much times
that times this number again times the
one dollar so let me write that down on
day one on day one on day one maybe I
have one dollar that I owe them on day
to day two it'll be one dollar times
this thing 1.00 six to seven four on day
three on day three I'm going to have to
pay 1.00 actually I forgot to zero
oh six to seven four times this whole
thing so on day three will be one dollar
which is the initial amount I borrow
times 1.000 this number six to seven
four
that's just that there and I want to pay
that much interest on this whole thing
again I'm compounding 1.000 six to seven
four so as you can see we've kind of
kept the balance for two days and I'm
raising this to the second power if I'm
multiplying it by itself I'm squaring it
so if I keep that balance for 365 days I
have to raise it to the 360 fifth power
and this isn't counting any kind of
extra penalties or fees so let's figure
out and this right here this number
whatever it is this is if I once I get
this and I subtract one from it that is
the mathematically true that is the
effective annual percentage rate so
let's figure out what that is so if I
take one point zero zero zero six two
seven four and I raise it I raise it to
the to the 365 power I get one point two
five seven so if I were to compound this
much interest 0.06 percent for 365 days
at the end of a year I would or the 365
days I would oh one point two five seven
times my original prints all about so
that's so this right here this right
here is equal to one point two five
seven so I would a one point two five
seven times my original principal amount
or the effective interest rate let me do
it in purple the effective interest rate
effective APR annual percentage rate or
the mathematically correct annual
percentage rate here is twenty five
point seven percent and you might say
hey Sal you know that's still not too
far off from the reported APR where they
just take 22 when they just take this
number and multiply by 365 instead of
taking this number and taking to the 365
power you're saying hey this is only a
this is roughly 23% this is roughly 26
percent it's only a three percent
difference but if you look at that
compounding interest video even the most
basic one that I've put out there you'll
see that every percentage point really
really really really matters especially
if you're going to carry these balances
for a long period of time so be very
careful in general you shouldn't carry
any
on your credit cards because these are
very high interest rates and you'll end
up just being paying interest on
purchases you made many many years ago
and you've long ago lost all of the joy
of that purpose so I encourage you to
not even keep balances but if you do
keep any balances pay very close
attention to this that that 22.9% APR is
still probably not the full effective
interest rate which might be closer to
26% in this example and that's before
they even count the penalties and the
other types of fees that they might
throw on top of everything